hey guys Rob here joined by the
beautiful to walk beautiful Wow the was
a straight fire a wonderful tomorrow
he's saying he's been playing Street
Fighter 5 huh
you've been playing it for like four
hours right I played it for four hours
I'm one of the first people to play it
humble brag it's quite a privilege and
we there's like three brand-new features
in the game that we want to talk to you
guys about yep let's let's go through
right now so the first one is called V
skill these skill yes this will be
places the old focus attack yeah it's
it's the same input and it's a you press
it by immediately press medium punch and
medium kick and you get at the same time
and you get a unique action for each
character so this is different for every
single character so in in Street Fighter
4 you would press medium punch and kick
and they would do that slow animation
yep and then you that's gone that is
gone yeah there's nothing like that in
this you've got instead a specific move
which as you can see here for ryu is a
counter which is a parry kind of thing
that's three five three so basically
he's parrying when you press yep medium
punch and medium kick at the same time
yeah so you can parry fireballs as you
can see here and you can any multi-hit
attack is possible to parry I've been
told that it is possible to do evil
moment 37 I think it is we've died goal
if you get the beast being unleashed you
can do that we're full of em yah go
actually see if you if you're watching
the for H head there's a to hit there
which I did manage to parry there so any
multi hit move you can parry now let's
just compare it for a second to third
strike so with third strike you stab
forward in ordinary right yeah you have
the same level of freedom it's it's it
doesn't require as much position
precision like for example the Tenjin
hadouken which is the move that we can
see redoing occasionally here and once
he's active access his state that is
quite easy to parry as long as you hit
the first one so once you once you hit
that first move the first hit of the
special move is that one right there
yeah you can pretty much keep hammering
it behind you it is beautiful people
saying that it doesn't look great just
look at that I've been staring at that
one animation for a long time so it only
has a different type oof
yeah so everyone's got a different
v-skill her one is a kind of lateral
upwards jump it's like a toy to me it
looks like it does hit on the way up
right the thing the thinking behind it
is Charlie's normal jumps don't travel
far across the screen they travel hide
that have a higher yeah so this is
something to kind of get her over fire
balls and give her some lateral motion
at the very peak of her jump she can go
into head stomps as you see there which
yep three hit headstones and you can
stop in between any of them so you can
do some tricky stuff if you want to
there's very opening to a combo it can
be yeah at the very top you as you saw
earlier she's got her lightening legs in
the air which kind of slow her descent
which I'm imagining people are going to
be quite tricky with to cause a bit of
confusion we're looking at Charlie here
now and you can see there his move this
looks so it's called the I think it's
the bullet grabber believe it's called
he eats foiled yeah this is incredible
so Charlie Charlie's one of the few
characters that can actually use the V
skill to build the V Gorge ordinarily
you just take you build it when you take
damage but he can put it fibers in a
pocket and keep it we've moved on to
poisons there yeah this is lucky this is
the same idea but it's a fiber reflect
yeah so Charlie puts the fireballs in
his pocket bison sends them back because
he's evil like that yeah and he doesn't
build any meter from it so yeah those
are the V skills for each of these
characters they're interesting I think
they're gonna they still require skill
to use but I have a lot of kind of
strategic value we're looking right now
we're looking at V trigger this is the
second new feature in the game how do
you activate the trigger so that's
pressing hard punch and hard kick at the
same time when your V Gorge is at max
okay so the V gauge is above the yeah
yeah different so how'd you build up
Vigo the V gauge like I said earlier is
from taking damage then for Charlie it's
for
yeah from pocketing energy fireballs and
stuff like that
so reuse one activates a dangerous state
which gives him his dungeon hadouken
chun-li's one actually makes her normals
multi-hit so yeah it's differently
effects it has is different for each
character so we've Ryu he's got his
dungeon which means it kind of ups his
damage potential for chun-li it's like
pressure and combo potential as well as
you can see here her kicks are doing
more poke on the way down just that's
just a normal jumping hard kick so
everything's got a little bit extra into
it and I reckoned that you could
probably get some good juggling out of
it I didn't get a chance to check
because my timing was a bit rubbish how
long does the V trigger law usually for
some it's different it differs from
person to person because if you've got
some characters that when you execute a
special move it will take one of the
stocks whereas others it's it's because
it's bestowing a state it's a timing
based thing so time based things so
you've got X amount of seconds to use it
what we're looking at here is Bisons 1
and bison becomes a bit of a maniac when
he's accessing yeah he's basically
unlocking his psycho potential you can
see hey does this teleport which is
pretty amazing then he comes back for
another one pretty amazing that's
fantastic yeah but that's only when he
activates d true yeah
that is his head stomped on nothing like
that and when you're doing them without
he's also got like this teleport his
teleport has a chained effect which we
saw in the trailer so you he teleports
forward a little bit and then teleports
again it and he kind of like gets a
speed boost out of it as well well it
makes him incredibly aggressive 4 which
is I reckon that's the way they want you
to play him does it make him a little
bit faster as well in his normal state
he's quite slow so he's a lot quicker
here you also saw there he's got he
doesn't have a psycho crusher anymore he
has that fireball which is from alpha
that's the alpha version so in his
triggered state the fireball gets it
travels across the screen mm-hmm
Charlie's v-trigger it's it's actually
one of the few that you has three
activation inputs so you can do forward
and hard punch and hard kick back hard
punch and hard kick
and up and hotter conch and a hug kick
and it's just about maneuverability so
it's moving him around we're actually
looking at V reversals now though yeah
this is the third new feature to the
game so what is a V reverse it's pretty
much alpha counters so when you're
getting hit and you're guarding you just
press forward and three punch and three
kick and every one has an animation
which kind of pushes them back and gives
you some space but it does it does
require you to be on point with you good
timing because if you do it late or you
do it too early you will leave yourself
open a bit so if I hit you and you be
reversed
do you take damage still I don't believe
I do I think it's just nullifying the
damage oh right okay so it is a little
bit like a focus attack again it is a
little bit like a focus attack but it's
not as it did the damage output that you
from a focus attack isn't there so with
a focus attack if you hold it for long
enough after that you could pretty much
unleash level three and you're done okay
well that was our breakdown of all the
new features in Sarah and our way down
that's how we roll of all the new
features in Street Fighter 5 we've also
got a video on the site of our general
impression so if you want to hear us
talk about how awesome weeping voice and
looks at the white hair and the massive
trench coat then it take a look at that
video and obviously for more features
and news and analysis of street fighter
stay tuned to game spot
[Music]